il s'agissait à l'époque de d'illustrer
un petit peu le point de vue africain
sur l'esclavagé et non seulement le
point de vue même la façon de faire et
traditionnelles artisanale donc celle de
ces fameux temps tueries d'abobo mais
qui avaient été amenés dans cette
capitale par le roi il ya quelques
siècles déjà et qui opère ce qu'on
appelle des appliqués collet c'est à
dire les toiles sont découpé cousu de
façon à former des images et des scènes
comme le c'est une exposition qui a été
réalisé par 200 à 300 personnes en une
quarantaine de tableaux qui illustrent
dans cette longue histoire de l
esclavage du début jusqu'à l'abolition
de 1848
d'où le titre texture textures et table
une chose tisser et a deux fils
entremêlés
il s'agit toujours l'histoire est
toujours une histoire de feeling entre
bulle et de fil tressé et surtout cette
façon de dire les choses à travers la
toile à travers le tissu avec simplement
le tissu et les mots en essayant
d'éviter au possible de passer par les
martiniquais ont beaucoup à voir avec le
bénin car une pourcentage très important
les esclaves qui arrivaient ici
provenaient de la connaissance
qu'avaient et particulièrement du port
de rui da qui est le grand port négrier
du bénin donc il y a des liens
fraternels les liens historiques des
liens de cosi nage culturel et beaucoup
de choses à faire ensemble et c'est là
en tout cas ça a été
pour cette occasion là l'occasion de
faire des choses ensemble